We're joined for this segment,
but with Derwyn button,
who is the chief public
defender for Orleans parish.
That's New Orleans,
Louisiana.
Derwin thank you so much for
being here with us today.
Thank you for having me.
Well,
I wanted you to talk just a little bit
about your office in New Orleans and the
challenges of representing poor people
accused of crimes in New Orleans.
Well,
I think our challenges aren't unique
to a lot of offices we have in our,
in our state and in our city,
a large volume of cases,
a large volume of serious cases and very
few resources to handle all of those
cases.
And we've been fighting over the last few
years trying to even the playing field
and trying to provide excellent public
defender services for poor folks in the
parish.
And it's been,
it's been up and down,
but we've been largely
successful in a lot of ways.
We've had our setbacks,
but the challenges remain
like everybody else's,
you know,
sort of resources,
uh,
trying to get resources
to folks who need them.
And talk a little bit about how the lack
of resources and when you've actually
lost some funding in the last few years,
how does that affect your lawyers and
how does that affect the way your office
handles cases?
Well,
from a very technical standpoint,
it increases caseload caseload begins
to rise as you begin to lose lawyers.
And as you begin to lose staff,
uh,
collateral,
staff,
investigators,
uh,
court support,
those kinds of folks,
it makes the workload and much harder
because you're asking everybody in the
office to do more.
And so you,
what you have is a lot
of very overburdened,
overworked staff and that can
take its toll on your staff.
So your turnover rate
may begin to be affected.
Also your preparation for cases.
If you,
you begin to triage more and more as a
front line defender so that you try to
figure out,
uh,
unfortunately,
in many cases how to cut
corners to handle what,
what are the most serious
first and then move on down.
So what it really means is each client
doesn't get the individual lives
representation that we would hope.
No.
And that's exactly,
that's exactly right.
And in the case of our office
law at the beginning of 2012,
we had to cuddle.
A lot of staff had to,
we had huge layoffs about
a third of our staff,
but rather than just embrace
all these extra cases,
what we had to do is simply
stopped taking them because we,
we,
we had the money to represent the folks
that we could represent and use the
staff that we could responsibly
represent everyone else.
We began what was,
what was a waitlist for representation
and who handled those other cases when
your office can't handle a case?
Who represents the
defendants in those cases?
Well,
what we did is we reached
out to the private bar,
the local bar,
and we created a pro bono consortium and
we reached out to some of the corporate
law firms in New Orleans who were very
active already with our office and they
were able to take some cases,
uh,
from the,
from the wait list.
The,
the judges started appointing,
uh,
lawyers as well.
And they were doing cases pro bono,
uh,
as well on those cases.
But there was still a few
because of the volume of cases,
there were a few folks who just sat
unrepresented for probably about three
months without any lawyer at all,
without any lawyer at all.
Let me ask you to describe a
little bit in Louisiana generally,
uh,
capital representation.
Somebody is facing the
death penalty in Louisiana,
sends to a number of people to death
and it's carried out a number of
executions.
How,
what's the system if there is one in
Louisiana for providing representation to
people facing the death penalty?
Well,
the system in Louisiana is,
uh,
is a bit of a,
of a quilt.
So you have 42 judicial districts,
each with their own chief
and chief public defender,
public defenders.
At the first level it's the district.
And so some districts contract with folks,
some districts handle it in house.
And also within those different districts,
you have nonprofits who handle capital
cases at the trial level as well.
And so what happens is if your charged
with a capital crime in Louisiana,
you can have the district,
you could have a district contractor or
you could have a nonprofit representing
you.
Just depending on sort
of where you line up in,
in the order of cases as they come in.
And just speaking generally,
does a quality of representation
differ between those different ways of
providing representation?
No,
that's an incredibly uneven.
We,
we have our state,
our Louisiana public defender board,
which was sort of reformed and revamped,
uh,
in 2007 now controls the
sort of certification of
capital lawyers and is trying
to have a more robust program
in how they certify lawyers.
And so some of the lawyers who
used to handle capital cases,
for example,
very few,
but some were decertified for example,
because they just weren't
living up to standard.
And you still had others that in the
districts who didn't have resources.
So capital cases have to be
staffed up with two attorneys,
mitigation specialist and investigator.
Some of the districts can't afford that
or are gambling that the case won't stay
capitol.
So what you'll get,
maybe it's just one lawyer on the capital
case hoping that it gets indicted to
as something lesser or that they can
work with the da to make it something
lesser.
But of course,
invariably those cases come back capital
and all of a sudden you're behind in
your representation.
And so,
uh,
not only do you have a
quality differential because
some lawyers simply aren't
ready,
right.
But you also have a resource differential
cause you just don't have the
resources to staff them up.
In some parishes,
actually a case can just sit for
even years waiting to be funded.
Is that true?
That is absolutely true.
Um,
one of our most,
uh,
most unique cases in Louisiana was
citizens citizen versus Louisiana or
Louisiana versus citizen.
And what his son was an individual that
was his name was the citizens as race is
a man named citizen,
a man named citizen.
Um,
and what happened in that case
is that they just didn't have,
they ran out of money for the
representation and filed for,
uh,
for systems with resources got
denied everywhere they went.
And the court stopped the case and
went up to our Louisiana Supreme Court.
And the Louisiana Supreme Court said,
you either find money or you
have to hope prosecution.
You can't prosecute a without a defense.
And by the way,
your speedy trial clock is ticking
like this doesn't stop any of that.
And what they found was the parish,
this was in Calca shoot,
Paris is southwest Louisiana,
Lake Charles Lake Charles,
all around the municipality.
There were fun balances.
There were reserves,
right?
No one wanted to give to public defense.
You had a multimillion dollar reserve,
uh,
with what's called the police jury,
which is law enforcement
funding mechanisms.
There you had a fun balance,
a reserve with the
district attorney's office,
a reserve with the sheriff or reserve
with the courts and none of them.
And these are multimillion
dollar reserves.
None of them wanted to
provide any additional funds
so that the sixth amendment
could be realized in this capital case.
It was really remarkable.
So that fun was funding.
The law enforcement is funding the courts
and is funding the district attorney's
office,
but absolutely no money for the
public defender now and still doesn't.
It still does and still doesn't.
And that's why what you have right
now in Lake Charles for example,
their public defender's office is right
in the middle of a service restriction.
They had to withdraw from about 400 cases.
Wow.
Because they simply couldn't
afford to handle it.
Wow.
Well,
I know at one time,
Jason Manual Reeves,
a case that came out of Calcasieu parish,
they had had the,
one of those nonprofit organizations
represented him at his first trial.
But then at the second trial,
the judge took them off and put the
local public defender and I think he was
carrying like 500 cases.
Oh yeah.
At that time,
that public defender's office,
they've gone through some changes,
but at that time,
and still now the case wildly
exceed a national standards by,
by almost any measure.
You've got lawyers who carry
about 800 misdemeanors,
for example,
which is about twice the national
standard and about 400 felonies,
again,
about twice the national standard.
So you're taking those lawyers that
are already handling twice a national
standard,
and then you give them a
capital case on top of that.
That's exactly,
that's exactly what happens.
And one of the cases that was recently
argued in the u s supreme court was a
case called Boyer,
uh,
Louisiana versus Boyer.
And what happened in Boyers case is
there was simply no money to fund his
representation.
And so it took him,
I think,
five years to get to trial on this case,
right.
Not because it was a particularly
complex and long case,
but they simply were slow going
because they didn't have the money.
Right.
And there is,
there's a question now of
on the speedy trial issue,
whose fault is it?
Right?
Should this,
should this be,
this conviction be
reversed and kicked out?
And so we're awaiting word
from the Supreme Court,
uh,
on that case in the state took the
position in that case that they were not
responsible for the delight.
That's correct.
Even though obviously the
state of Louisiana has the
money to pay for a defense
if they want it.
When you seek the death pony,
Louisiana,
it's sort of the name of the state,
isn't it?
Yeah,
that's absolutely correct.
And their position was,
so what,
my goodness,
what,
uh,
what are you doing in New Orleans?
Uh,
with regard to representing
people in capital cases?
Well,
we just started a capital division.
Uh,
what we've been able to do over the
past four years is really grow a lot of
strong talent in our office and
wanted to figure out how to provide
representation basically
all the way through,
uh,
in,
in every sort of case that could enter
the parish while at the same time
continuing,
uh,
a sort of tradition of excellence because
we were having the same problem as the
rest of the state was with Tom Tractors
who were sort of problematic and how
they were,
they were staffing up.
And these are people who would contract
to handle cases for like a flat fee?
Well,
we,
it's a fee for service for capital,
but there's,
there's very few capitol certified
lawyers around the state.
And we wanted to sort of create a
pipeline to certify lawyers inside,
uh,
our staff.
And,
and it was a way for folks to sort of
move through the leadership ranks in the
office along with building
different capacities.
So we started a capital,
a defender,
a division in our office this year.
How many lawyers do you have in hand?
Right now,
we just have,
we just have two lawyers.
And so we still contract with a sort
of trusted folks for any cases that go
beyond standard right now.
Uh,
but we,
you,
my,
uh,
deputy chief,
leads the division and as an
excellent lawyer and has one,
one praise from many different corners of,
uh,
of lawyering.
So we're very,
very proud of how the
program is progressing.
They also have a nice,
uh,
a great young lawyer who had experience
with in Bryan Stevenson's shop at Eji in
Alabama and is always sort of
wanted to be a capital defender.
So we're,
we're excited about what's to come.
That's going to be a big challenge
with your resources though,
right?
Cause that one capital cases is going
to take a whole lot more resources than
many,
many misdemeanor cases
or less serious felony.
Okay.
No,
and that's,
that's exactly what we're seeing.
And so we're going to be really talking
with local stakeholders and the state to
s to talk about how since we do have this
division now that we're going to need
the resources to staff it.
And we in Orleans parish,
our district attorney doesn't have the
sort of appetite for capital cases that
others do.
So we're hoping that will be,
that's a change.
It's a real change.
He started sort of guns blazing,
but found out that it,
it is incredibly sort of wasteful,
uh,
and uh,
and costly,
uh,
for these cases in Orleans parish,
the case,
he,
he actually began his
career with a capital case,
uh,
as Da,
whereas with a capital case
actually won a capitol conviction,
but because of an
enormous Brady violation,
well,
it is figured to disclose
exculpatory evidence.
Right?
Right.
Because of a huge,
a Brady violation,
that case was reversed and um,
then then ultimately resolved
with a manslaughter conviction.
So it was one of those.
So I think after that experience,
he's like,
all right,
that was a whole lot of money for nothing.
And we don't see a lot of
capital indictments anymore.
And of course when Harry
Connick was a district attorney,
you had lots of capital cases and lots
of violations of failure to turn over
exculpatory evidence,
lots of violations,
very almost no capital convictions and
no death sentences for out of Orleans for
more than a decade.
But he still kept them coming.
And what we're also finding
out now through subsequent
litigation is that wasn't
playing by the rules,
right?
So how much of a drain it is on your
system is going to depend very much on
those two decisions the prosecutor makes,
whether to seek the death Polly and then
whether to resolve the case with some
sort of plea offer.
That's exactly right.
And that's what we see,
um,
in our,
in our parish right now.
Uh,
the big,
the big bottleneck is when are
you going to make a real decision,
Mr Da.
So from arrest,
the police will arrest F at for first
degree and then he has 120 days to decide
if he wants to,
whether going to go capital or not,
but we have to staff
it in that time period.
Right?
Like,
it's a capital k capital and that's,
that's how we move forward in our office.
So the faster that decision comes,
uh,
the less strain on our resources we have
because it's an enormous responsibility
to investigate the life and
background of the client mitigation,
all those things that you would not
do if the case was not capitalism.
No.
And that's exactly right.
And I think that's what
a lot of folks miss.
Uh,
particularly a lot of Das and Louisiana,
uh,
district attorneys,
because we recently had,
we were recently had staff in Boston,
uh,
researching the life of,
of a client who's charged capital and
they don't understand why you running back
to Boston.
Right?
And it's like,
because his,
his life led him through there
and we have to figure out,
um,
we have to investigate everything,
right?
Because we're trying to save a mans life.
And so they,
the system in Louisiana,
it doesn't really get it.
The prosecutorial side
doesn't really get it,
but those were enormous
strains on resources.
What Derwyn Bunton we're so glad to
have you and we wish you the best and
getting the resources you need.
I know you've been getting a recruiting,
some great lawyers for your office.
Uh,
but I know the case loads the workloads
and everything depends upon having the
resources.
And,
uh,
you've been the public defender
chief defender there for four years,
and,
uh,
we,
we thank you for making the time to be
with us today and wish you the best.
No,
well,
thank you for having me.
Sure.